[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys welcome to another episode of
the octo boys youtube channel and we're
doing another axe restoration video as
if we don't have enough axes already but
still we're gonna have fun you know
today is a perfect day to do an axe
restoration project
it is raining it's cold I don't want to
be out foraging or fishing and I just
kind of want on something fun to do in
the garage here for a nice little lazy
Saturday and so Tommy will you help me
pick out an axe to do all right
so let me show you my axes and let's
pick one to start on why don't you show
me your favorite axes which one should
we do once you pull out a couple hey
Tommy you picked a really good one here
this is a bearded axe from Eastern
Europe you can see it's a hewing X it's
flat on one side it's meant for making
boards and it's a pretty light line axe
oh I don't think it's meant for heavy
duty swinging this is more like
finishing work and look at these cool
designs that someone put on there that
is really neat so we don't want to grind
off these designs so I'm not going to
use grow angle grinders or anything like
that on it but I want to get the rust
off without ruining the metal and it's
in pretty good shape there's a little
bit of mushrooming right there I see
where someone's been banging on that and
you can see right here it's a little bit
dented in where somebody's been whacking
on that I'd like to fix both those
things but other than that that looks
really good there's a seam a crack in
here from the forging process but I'm
not too worried about that Sachs has
gone through a lot of age a lot of abuse
and it hasn't broken yet it won't break
on me what do you think we should use
for an axe handle this one you know what
kind of wood that is it's called purple
heartwood it's a pretty cool when you
polish it all up it turns deep purple
Oh Aunt lottie's going to like just X we
might be able pulse it up so and they
might think it's her yeah
alright tomboy I got an idea I I think
we should soak it in this bucket of a
vapor rush to get the rust off without
hurting it and I think what we need to
do is heat up this end of this eye and
bang it back out flat without using the
four yeah because it's raining outside
so maybe I'll use my Mac gas torch
that's how a good idea yeah it's right
over there
after we get done fixing the eye we can
put it in a vapor rust and work on the
handle while it soaks so good alright
let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
so we got the back of the eye so it's
not quite as beat in it's a little bit
more flat and here on this part where it
was mushroomed over I tried uncurl it a
little bit now it's a little ragged on
the edge but I think we can clean that
up in it then you give us a few
millimeters extra that we would have
otherwise lost so but let this cool down
and go on to the next step you know how
I talked a big game earlier about that
crack not making me worried look at that
that thing opened way up I think that
was from what I was heating and beating
on it that straightened out the eye that
looks pretty hairy right now not gonna
lie that's concerning but there you go I
learned something new when you heat
steel red-hot and beat it with hammers
it makes cracks worse okay now that I
say it out loud it sounds pretty obvious
but any rate we're gonna keep going
because we're in too deep and there's no
turning back
so hurrah let's go keep doing it
[Music]
all right got this bucket of a vapor
rust now let this thing sit and some a
vapor Russ all right we got that ax-head
soaking in the vapor rust it's great
stuff it'll dissolve the rust and you
can leave it in as long as you want it
doesn't hurt the base metal so we're
gonna just let that sit in there and I'm
gonna go take a dinner break and then I
can work on that handle some more that
axe had sittin in the vapor rust and
it's about ready and I'm gonna pull it
out here in a few minutes but first I'm
going to shape out this handle and to
start with I'm just gonna knock the
corners off make it kind of a circular
oval and we'll go from there
[Music]
well there we go got the handle done and
sanded it's a kind of a blocky shape
which I kind of like but not too bad at
all so let's check out the head and see
how it's doing well there we go looks
pretty good got all the rust off but
didn't take away the etchings it didn't
hurt any of the base metal looks good
[Music]
that's that's pretty sharp not too bad
but I've got a problem with the handle
this is a hewing axe you see how it's
flat and slightly off-center it's bent
for going down the side of a log and
making it flat you know making a beam or
a board you see how this handle is
sticking out so when you go down the
wood it'll boom hit the handle and you
won't be able to just shave along the
side this is also a healing axe and if
you look the handle is curved right and
you can get that right taking a larger
piece of wood and carving a curved
handle or you can do it by steam bending
and I have never done steam bending
before so I want to give it a try but
I'm jumping into the deep end of the
pool here this is kiln dry and purple
hardwood a very hard dense wood much
harder than Hickory it's got a very
dense porous structure so getting the
steam to penetrate this wood is going to
be tricky and it's a substantially thick
piece of wood it's been killing drying
and then kiln dried wood the hardwoods
like this are prone to cracking and
breaking when you try to steam bend them
and I need to think of some way to rig
something up so that I can soak this in
hot water for a long period of time all
right guys I figured out how I'm going
to soak the wood in hot water here we go
we got the jacuzzi 104 degrees
Fahrenheit bubbly hot freshwater and
what I've done
they're kind of this big ziploc bag in
here pull-up Jacuzzi water and I've got
the Purple Heart wood sitting inside
I've got the back because my wife was a
little concerned that I might stain the
water and get it all nasty if I soaked
wood in it for like a week so we're
soaking it in the bag contaminating the
jacuzzi but so far it's been in about 20
hours and it has turned water into that
a little bit brownish yeah we'll see
it's maybe a little soft at the surface
but the water really has it penetrated
very deep yet I think it's going to need
to be in this water for a very long time
before we can attempt to steam it in any
sort of bed but I've never done this
before so it didn't venture yeah let's
give that a couple more days see what
happens well this handles been soaking
the jacuzzi for five days now so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna put it onto a
jig and start to bend it and put it back
in the jacuzzi for a little bit let it
soak a little bit longer and then we're
gonna see how that goes and steam it
well I can tell the wood is soaked up a
bit of water because the head definitely
doesn't fit on anymore but that's just
fine so put this spacer right here so
I'm gonna go check this back in the
jacuzzi for a couple more days and then
we're gonna try to steam it all right
guys the woods been soaking in the
jacuzzi for nine days now at 104 degrees
let's see
see how we're doing so just soaking it
in the hot water with the clamps on has
worked the wood a little bit but we're
going to stick it in the oven at about
275 degrees with a bunch of steaming
water underneath it and see if we can't
get a little bit more bed now that it's
soaked for over a week oh oh
the ovens a little bit too small so what
I'm gonna do is Emma let this dry for a
couple days and then we get when the
hair with the angle grinder see what we
can come up with that way yeah bezel
laid plans of mice and men and all that
alright it's been about 90s in the hot
tub and about seven days drawing so
let's take it off and see what we got
look how much that's rebounding look at
that
that hardly bent it at all oh jeez but I
did succeed in putting a crack that runs
down almost the entire length of the
wood so yay see what it did to the chunk
of cedar that I was using as a spacer
put a little bend in the angle iron I
think I bent it more than I did the
purple heartwood
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right there we go
sure is pretty disappointed about the
handle not curving like I wanted to but
man it's good looking though well there
it is that's well it sure turned out
pretty but I'm a little disappointed
with the handle it really needs to curve
over and I should have cut it off about
right there to make it a one-handed at
number this is not a two-handed big old
hefty thing this is for doing fine
carpentry work you know as a hewing axe
but that's okay because the handle
didn't turn out quite the way I want I
think I'm going to do is pop the handle
off and use it for another project maybe
turn it into a tomahawk handle or use it
for an axe handle so I didn't chop it
short or because I think I'm going to
reuse it for something else but I'm not
going to do it in this video I'm gonna
hang this up on the wall think about it
for a little bit and they want to come
back at it again later maybe I'll try it
again with the softer piece of wood
something like a Hickory or oak or
something that will steam a little bit
better and then set up a proper steaming
setup instead of trying to jerry-rig
something with the hot tub in an oven
but you know it was fun and that's the
whole point of these things just to have
some fun right but thanks for watching
guys we hope you enjoyed this video if
you'd like to see some more successful
axe restoration videos check the link
below I'll put my tool restoration
playlist link in the bottom but thanks
for watching guys don't forget to click
Subscribe thanks
if you liked this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching